we turn now to something called the
wagner group its innocuous sounding name
belies the ugly truth about the wagner
group a collection of russian
mercenaries with a track record of
brutality and war crimes now dispatched
by vladimir putin to ukraine
that's right brian little is known about
them except they are believed to be one
of putin's secret weapons in his efforts
to inflict pain on civilians
and they are being closely watched by
u.s officials
it would be
wrong to say that
that
by using foreign fighters we have sort
of greater worries about brutality
because the russian forces themselves
have been
uh brutal uh in some of the worst ways
uh but it is i think a statement of mr
putin's desire to to bolster his
manpower
in response to the depletion of that
manpower over the last six weeks
to get a better understanding of the
secretive group we're joined now by
jason blizekis a senior research fellow
at the safan group thank you so much for
being here jason why are they called the
wagner group for starters
so they were founded about a decade ago
by an individual by the name of dmitry
utkin and dimitri luken is an individual
who used the call sign wagner and is an
individual who had a great love for
the uh uh the most uh virulent of of
nazis adolf hitler and adolf hitler's
favorite composer was richard wagner so
who can took the moniker wagner group to
name his private military company that
um and there is this neo-nazi connection
dust to the wagner group and they are
very active throughout the globe sadly
and we've seen evidence of that across
the world really of their brutality
we see it in ukraine right now um there
are reports from the united nations that
go back nearly two years ago that the
organization was involved in heinous
human rights abuses in the central
african republic and just a few days ago
um there are reports that the wagner
group was engaged in a false flag
operation that led to the deaths of
individuals in mali and they were
creating a grave trying to blame the
french military for these deaths of
these individuals
likely at the hands of the wagner group
jason a question for you from rhonda
schwartz rhonda
in your new research report you also
talk about the role of foreign fighters
from the west what have you learned
about the role that they're playing who
are those folks
so the russia ukraine conflict has
become a crucible for
melting pot if you will of individuals
with far-right sympathies who are
flocking to join the fight in some cases
to join the fight uh with the the
russians in some cases these are
individuals that are from russia going
into ukraine like the russian imperial
movement a far-right
terrorist group that was sanctioned by
the u.s department of state in 2020 in
some other cases you have had reports of
individuals from the united states
trying to join the fight in ukraine um
in some cases we have seen reports that
the so-called boogaloo boys um have
tried to go to ukraine to fight i think
in those reports they they were
discouraged by what they saw it and came
back essentially what you see is uh
nazis uh far-right individuals uh
primarily joining the russian side but
you do have some reports of individuals
joining the ukrainian side that may have
far-right sympathies as well so you see
upwards to perhaps uh thousands of
individuals making the travel the
pilgrimage if you will to to
ukraine to fight um precise numbers are
unknown but it's very uh disturbing to
see that the fight of foreign uh fire
fighters in fact there's even reports
that the russians are trying to bring
individuals from syria and iraq who have
uh battle-hardened skills to join the
fight on behalf of the russians paying
upwards to two thousand dollars per
individual so very disturbing reports
that we're seeing and jason given the
size of the russian army why does putin
need to dispatch the wagner group
so there are reports uh recent ones in
fact that there might be upwards to 8
000 members of the wagner group there in
ukraine and part of the reason being
that this provides some plausible
deniability to the russian government
the wagner group technically is not part
of the russian government but has been
used by the russians as a tool of their
foreign policy to give them this era of
aura of deniability essentially and in
this context they can go out and
oftentimes go to places not necessarily
being uniformed and do some really bad
things they can engage in reconnaissance
to provide information to the russian
conventional forces they can engage in
human rights abuses to target civilians
to try to get information from those
individuals um and generally cause chaos
and engage in brutality in an effort to
cow the ukrainian population essentially
to bend to the russian will
there are many other things that they're
involved in of course but these are just
some of the low lights and does their
command structure go up to the russian
army are they under the control of some
army
so the interesting thing about the
wagner group is that they are funded by
a close henchman of vladimir putin by
the individual by the name of yageni um
pergosian and pragosian is also known as
putin's uh chef he bankrolls the
organization so you can believe that
this is an organization absolutely that
is operating at the behest of the
russian federation at the perhaps the
highest levels
and they continue to be there in ukraine
now as best you know
they are and there was recent reports in
fact by a think tank that goes by the
name bellingcat that said that upwards
to three thousand members of the wagner
group have been killed and the wagner
group's also useful for the russian
federation because it could take
essentially the the death count and make
it lower for vladimir putin instead of
having russian conscripts and russian
military forces dying you have this
deniable force that's dying on behalf of
the russian federation and they don't
have to count towards the body count so
they're also useful for trying to keep
the russian domestic population happy
about this conflict is it clear that
putin though endorses their use and
enjoys having them on the field of
battle for himself
well he hasn't been explicit about that
but the fact that they're there that
they're operating in areas of the the
east and southern portions of ukraine
they were even up in the north portions
towards kiev um all of these uh are
examples that uh putin is allowing for
them to operate you know perhaps not
explicitly they have his implicit
approval all right jason vlazekis from
the soufon center thank you so much for
being with us here tonight
thank you brian you bet coming up next
this week's winners and losers in the
media see if you agree with the choices
made by the editors of mediaite
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the long crime trial network
time now for this week's winners and
losers in the media as chosen by the
editors of mediaite and we're joined by
aidan mclaughlin who is the
editor-in-chief of mediaite which like
the law and crime trial network is part
of the dan abrams media group and aiden
you've chosen as the winner this week
clarissa ward from cnn with incredible
reporting from the battlefield in
ukraine
all right
is everybody okay alexandra asks
our team member maria avdiva has cut up
her hands on broken glass
vladimir treats her injuries as
alexandra calls the dispatch again to
find where the wounded are
you got no connection we're sitting in
the entrance she says
and they're shelling the shit out of us
well aidan reporting from the front
lines uh incredible job by clarissa ward
right and this is what we know clarissa
ward for she's a cnn senior
international correspondent she's
reported from war zones all across the
world she uh is currently in kharkiv in
ukraine um which is the subject of heavy
russian fire um and did this report
where she basically her and her crew the
cnn crew trailed uh ukrainian paramedics
as they went into places that had been
bombed by russia by the russian military
and tried to rescue victims on the
ground um now the report delved into a
russian tactic known as doubletap
striking which is where russian
artillery bombs a place and then the the
planes circle around wait for the
paramedics to run in and then drop
another bomb
which is a pretty horrific
strategy for war that was used in syria
a lot when when russia was helping the
assad regime fight there
but it was truly impressive brave
reporting from clarissa ward and her cnn
team
they actually had to dodge fire at one
point as you saw in that video
it's what we've come to expect from
curse award but it makes it no less
impressive indeed
and for a loser this week you've chosen
former congressperson
devin nunes who left congress to become
part of the donald trump social media
outlet which hasn't done so well here's
how he tried to justify it
twitter right now is nothing but a pr
wire uh it's it's got a global footprint
but there's just nobody there and i mean
and how do you explain
how we have more engagement on true
social than they have on twitter
a brave front there but what's the
problem for him right so that claim that
truth social has had more engagement
than twitter um most people have uh sort
of dismissed that as patently false um
true social is uh the social media
platform that got launched by trump uh
to compete with twitter devin nunes left
congress to join truth social as its ceo
now the launch of truth social uh which
came a couple weeks ago uh was
marred by a bunch of technical issues uh
at one point there was a wait list that
was said to have been of a million
people all trying to get on the platform
uh we had a reporter actually that got
on truth social recently
and wrote about uh for mediaite all of
the various problems with it
one big problem donald trump doesn't
even use truth social um donald trump
has yet to post on it or he posted a
couple times when it first came out has
not posted on it since february um so
trump isn't even using his own platform
uh he says that he's not going to be
coming back to twitter even if elon musk
restores his account that he's gonna be
staying with truth social um but elon
musk is now going after truth social he
said uh on twitter today uh that it has
a terrible name and he actually made a
good point he said it only exists uh
because twitter he said censored free
speech and that's a good point in the
problem for truth social and devin nunes
going forward it's that without twitter
being considered to be since
cracking down on conservatives there's
no reason for truth social and if
conservatives see twitter as being saved
by elon musk then they're going to
return to that social media platform
they're not going to use something like
truth social which does not have the
audience and doesn't have the user
experience that twitter has so in short
elon musk may doom truth social you know
that's what people are saying and uh in
fact the company that truth social is
trying to uh go public with that they
made a spec with um
which is trading publicly uh their
stocks dropped 50 percent uh since march
so i think it's clear that investors at
least do not see truth social as a
viable social media platform going
forward and you certainly have chosen a
good loser and devin nunes given all the
events that are surrounding truth social
and twitter aiden thank you so much for
being here and thanks to all of you for
watching we'll see you again back here
next week on the law and crime trial
network
[Applause]
you